our legal system traditionally has been
based on a theory of deterrence you
threaten punishment and if somebody does
a criminal act you punish them you do
something to them that they don't want
to have happen to them you put them in
prison you execute them in extreme cases
the new paradigm of suicide terrorism
makes our system of deterrence very hard
to operate especially when coupled with
individual guilt and individual
responsibility you could deter terrorism
if you punish the families of the
terrorists but we can't do that because
we believe in individual guilt so the
combination of the use of deterrence and
the requirement of individual guilt make
it impossible for us to use the
traditional legal methods and legal
threats against suicide terrorists
that's why we need to move in
preemptively that's what we have to stop
it from happening before it happens
without trying to analogize humans to
animals in any moral sense when you have
a person who will not fear death and
will not stop from doing anything
because of the threat of punishment you
really have to treat that person the way
you would treat a wild tiger or a wild
lion you don't reason with a lion you
don't try to deter a lion you stop the
lion by either building a cage between
you and the lion or by disabling the
lion or killing the lion and that method
has been adapted to the use against
suicide terrorism so that's the problem
we haven't figured out a solution to
that because our usual approach the rule
of law doesn't work we need to create a
new rule of law to govern the use of
suicide terrorism my optimism grows out
of the fact that there are people in the
world today we're trying to level the
playing field and give everybody a
chance to be successful and give them a
stake in peace in life the greatest
dangers we face today or
people who have such miserable lives and
such false promises of great deaths that
they prefer the illusion of paradise to
the reality and poverty of the present
time and I think we have to shift that
we have to shift that by making life on
Earth much better and by exposing the
myth of the hereafter one of the worst
myths that human beings ever created in
the service of religion particularly
rules that promised reward for murder in
a world to come very hard to talk people
out of that if they honestly believe in
the depths of their heart that if they
kill civilians they will be rewarded by
sexual fantasies by food fantasies by
all the great things that they're
deprived of in this world it's perverse
it's bizarre but it's a reality in many
people's lives
you